okay so here's a hot take pandas are
overrated sure they're cute so cute they
show up in our logos our movies and even
on our feet we're obsessed but every
obsession has a dark side and this one
starts in China the Chinese government
owns nearly all the giant pandas on
earth and American zoos will shell out
up to a million dollars a year to rent
just one most sign 10-year panda
diplomacy contracts and if any baby cubs
are born they pay an additional one-time
$400,000 baby tax that doesn't even
include extra costs like the Bears
enclosure medical care and mountains of
bamboo but zoos are far from going
bankrupt over pandas in 2012 attendance
at the edinburgh zoo rose 51 percent
after pandas arrived and the national
and atlanta zoos saw similar increases
well that money is great for the zoo's
it's not necessarily the best for the
pandas regardless of whether they are an
important source of revenue we do not
need any more pandas in captivity we
should stop reading them right away and
they are not ambassadors for their
species
turns out breeding pandas in captivity
is a completely different ballgame from
in the wild threesomes are more or less
the norm when it comes to wild panda sex
something that's really difficult to
replicate in zoos on top of that wild
pandas have a mating routine that
involves courting calls and scent
markings that can last weeks but in
captivity the chosen pair is often
separated right up to when the female is
ovulating and as a result they rarely
hit it off regardless we are dead set on
keeping the species alive and why
wouldn't we they're freaking adorable
the round heads seemingly large eyes and
Cabbage Patch Kid bodies remind us of
babies and that triggers a nurturing
response ultimately what it boils down
to is this people care about cute
critters period animals like ants and
some of the insects
farm work ecosystem value then do pandas
or elephants or wolves or all the
charismatic animals I mean they you know
it's a fact mangrove forests for example
support at least 1300 animal species
with their roots fruit and branches so
saving them is like saving their entire
ecosystem pandas by comparison don't
affect many other life forms so saving
them saves the pandas but not much else
yeah it's the cuddly pandas who qualify
as opposed to species for conservation
organizations not the mangroves and
that's a problem of the close to 20,000
endangered animal species only 80 get
the lion's share of the already scarce
funding and one study found that 61
percent of conservation campaigns only
raised funds for these celebrity species
but as the World Wildlife fund's logo
pandas really hit the ultimate
conservation jackpot when the World
Wildlife Fund was founded in 1961 it
distributed all printed materials in
black and white you know what else was
black and white pandas pandas looked
just as cute in color as they did in
greyscale so voila
the sad irony is the main reason pandas
were endangered in the first place is
habitat destruction yet even with all
their funding it's not enough to prevent
further habitat decline the reason
they're endangered is because of humans
is the major problem on this planet is
there's too many humans that and the
loss of habitat and because pandas are
specialists you know basically eating
bamboo when they lose their habitat
their homes they lose their lives
construction logging and an influx of
tourists continue to diminish and
disjoint the pandas natural habitat and
if the whole point of these hefty funds
and breeding programs is to rebuild wild
populations or sucking at it in 2006 the
Chinese government started reintroducing
pandas to the wild only five of those
seven are still alive in fact of all the
species listed as endangered since 1973
99% are still around but only 1% one
have been successfully
rehabilitated and taken off the list you
know some people say well if there were
no pandas in the wild would it be
worthwhile having pandas in captivity
and my answer is no I would rather see
the money go into preserving habitat and
then saving individuals of other species
maybe it's time to end the era of
pent-up panda bears
after all we'll always have Kung Fu
Panda
[Music]